so uh let's say
uh
i'm doing uh
these techniques there's a lot of elbow
power in this stuff it's not that my
hand is going around
there's a lot of elbow
okay same thing goes
on the other side there's a lot of elbow
power even on the
throw okay
or
even this way elbow pot
so he's coming in with whatever
it's not that i'm gonna hook here is
that holding the elbow is dropping
you see that crane shape
so very much like a hand sore so oh my
elbow's dropped me and you see not like
this
there's an elbow power uncured elbow is
the term
okay he said he's coming oh i dropped
that out
okay and then just like uh
you're gonna be fighting
i'm not cutting his hand down my center
drops center drop is dropping
and then my weight is over his head so
he can't stand up he's gotta you gotta
have to pick all the way up
so same thing on this drill
when i'm here
all my
weight is on him
my weight is on him
so
when he you'll feel you feel how he he
has to kind of stay still because when
he picks up his foot it'll take his
balance like all your
call cube
attacks his balance is dependent on me
you got it i'm i get him to that point
and he'll stop moving and then he picks
up his foot he'll lose his balance okay
so again just anything anchored elbow
kick for the chin strap
but
not like that
which will weight where when he tries to
pick up a foot it's gonna make him even
fall more okay got it
again
elbow anchor with my weight
then shoot it in for the chin strap here
and put your weight
and the angled attack is on his base
okay
keep this away from grabbing you
one more time
anchor
wait
yeah
okay let's try so this this is just
administrative okay anywhere
you can grab his head and he's not
charging you
uh it's gonna come up
do you understand
uh so i don't know let's say he's he's
he's trying to box his way and he's
trying to box his way in
okay so we're just administratively
starting it but not where he's just a
dummy i don't want to go back that far
okay so we're not
doing that
he's doing some sort of whatever with
his hands you see and you're going to
have to uh start with your test tobacco
right so if he keeps pushing
then you have pokey nugget do you
understand but he's not he's not pushing
anything
but he's giving me something
dynamic
to work with got it
okay
so don't stay standing and then they
come but you're not fighting them we're
not going there yet okay all right try
okay let's let's drill some uh dynamic
weight displacement okay so he's coming
in there's my arm contact there's the
center lowering boom i left the chin
strap so the first one we're gonna do
the first one i'm gonna do i already did
one right i'm on i'm on here on his toes
so when he picks up his feet it makes
him do that he falls do you get it okay
so the second one i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna push his weight into his
heels you see how i did that
push his weight into his heel
not pushing him back
right around here into his heels
okay
there he goes not from there again
here wave into his heels
just want to see if you can understand
where that is where that vector is
as much effort as it took me to drop my
weight that's how much effort you're
using here unfortunately you guys are
not
you guys are like here going
okay i'm i'm here look that's the in
space you see
that's how much effort it took
he goes i moved this side
again you're not going to clinch you're
not going to the clinch okay
now boom here
on the inside free it's free free to
move won't wait
okay
then here again
from here
it's free no resistance there's no need
to flex there well no resistance then my
ways just drop me okay
and then this cd so it's like i have my
pop
[Music]
okay let's go next vector i want you to
play with
is the one forward okay
so i'm going to use that chin strap
and bring him down
wait
chin strap bring him down
okay let's try that
[Music]
so
we're going to work on this
this chin strap and that anchored elbow
okay
so i'm going to pass him
there's that anchored elbow again
oh
i just throw the arm
here here i am i'm going to grab it here
throw it
keep this tight like a crane okay
let's try
all right so i i have that
kaizen noggin variations right here
i'm just doing the same technique
okay
move
here there we go
so just like in the
keyhole
you don't want him all the way up again
he's out
it's very trendy now
for you is bad for him
okay
so same thing here
my weight
is on him
he hasn't stood up
he can't stand up
okay
i can do the heel vector or i can do the
toe vector
and i don't let him off
the forearm
is gonna go around his head
you see
so
i'm trying to stand up it's my weight
again you see just like heightened
noggin okay and he's going that way i
just
turn that over
don't let him back up okay
go
start mixing up the grab attempt
not the zombie walk-in
[Music]
good wrap that forward around the top of
the head
too high he came out too high wrap your
forearm around the back of the head
that's better get you get off your heels
you're on your heels don't point your
toes away from each other
get out of his way
okay
this time i am going to do that other
version okay but it's a little
differently because i'm not going to be
on the head
okay
so i'm going to throw this forearm like
that do you see remember the chin strap
the chin strap
goes this way
keep it going
[Music]
so it looks like the other technique
but it's actually
nugget on
what i'm doing
[Music]
okay all right so on on my
nugget variation
i know i'm not turning him like that
because i don't want him to stand up
so you have this
torque
right there in his shoulder you see
and i make his head go under
that's what makes him fall
as opposed to
oh
it'll make an arm blow around you see
here
okay
so same thing here
whoa
that is what i want
you see that thing right there
now now i have a balance
okay
i tried it again get that torque in the
scapula mechanism what's up i'm gonna
punch him
boom
you have that rotational torque in your
strikes right
say yes yes
uh your rotational torque is everywhere
it's everywhere
everywhere
everywhere okay
so we're doing this one
and i'm gonna take this element off i'm
going to go for the chin strap
in the with the inward spiral you see
so i'm here and it does
you got it
and you can feel it again
here i'm not moving it over
i'm here
and i'm throwing it over so it goes
under the arm like in the other
technique remember that okay
so that's how i'm getting
that impingement i'm just going slow
because
i know him okay
now some ruques will bend their arm
and then
you would have shihanagi
but that's a scaredy uk okay
so
home
[Music]
okay if that comes up all right
switch rolls
keep that inwards fire that's the right
thing right length
okay
[Music]